good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy hump day
it doesn't feel like your average hump
day well that's because maybe not for
you but like some of us have to fast
tomorrow so i don't know maybe this week
is just feeling off for some of us this
week is feeling so full of promise for
me because you know i'm in my 10 days
i'm reflecting i'm repenting tomorrow
i'm looking forward to really
diving into the om you know no phone i
might even do no tv i might just do book
just to make it a little harder on
myself because i'm not fasting so for
those who don't know tomorrow is yom
kippur which is the day of atonement for
us jews we must fast all day whilst we
atone for our sins though pregnant
ladies need not fast um
and suddenly i'm feeling a kick
is that a child
yeah no i have to pass and usually like
we're commiserating together about you
know the nasty breath of everyone in
shul and i'll just be doing that by
myself this year because you've
abandoned me just like everyone else
i'll be waking up having breakfast
having lunch and then i'm actually going
to be hosting the breakfast which i'm
really excited about and it works out
for everyone else because no one else
has to go through the torture of
preparing a meal while they're fasting
it's only fair that you host the
breakfast i just want to say for the
last two years i have hosted the
breakfast and part of it is torture but
it's something to do yeah you know like
instead of just looking out the window
thinking about you know how you're a
terrible person and how hungry you are
it's something you're slicing tomatoes
like it's something and honestly i would
say 98 of the [ __ ] that is served at a
bagel breakfast breakfast
i like gag at like i was like unboxing
like herring and tuna and like honestly
it was making me not hungry like it's
disgusting the cutting of the bagels and
toasting them like that will kill you
yeah but i don't know the egg salad
slashing around in the container you
know what you're good at i think i could
fast another day
is there any requests that you have for
the breakfast i'm so [ __ ] glad you
asked i'm taking requests
okay can we please i know everyone loves
like a diverse bag of bagels and don't
get me wrong i do too but let's be real
like the plain ones go the fastest
because everyone loves a plane lane
nobody likes a plane nobody i wouldn't
have even gotten a plane if you hadn't
mentioned it
you're the only one who would go for a
plane baby well get a bunch because i'll
take some home fine like a lot i want
like an overflowing of bagels okay and i
know everyone likes let's get a cinnamon
raisin like
stick with like poppy sesame like a nice
of the the base the
the regulars okay snitch and i both are
gonna have cinnamon raisin as dessert
bagels of course but like
flavorless bagels just as for the
flavorless bagels like okay everything
is good of course when i break i just
want like a plain or even a poppy seed
that tastes like nothing or sesame
really tastes like nothing like
something a good base that's what i'll
say okay that's fine now
if i walk into your home and i see
philadelphia cream cheese i just want to
let you know i'm leaving well you're
going to see it because it's the
premiere cream cheese but you will also
see temp tea okay because
let's just rewind did you say it's the
premier cream cheese philadelphia cream
cheese is the only cream cheese worth
cheesing with cream wow i'm shocked i
know that you like they have a really
good scallion cream cheese i like all of
theirs tempty is so disgusting oh my god
i think cream cheese that is not whipped
literally deserves death jail to them
all so crazy but you know what different
strokes for different folks i'm gonna
have every cream cheese and i'm gonna
also have fresh cream cheese okay also i
know i don't know if you're gonna be
doing this like i really prefer to eat
off a paper plate okay that's just me
and honestly
beverages are also really important i
just placed a large beverage order and
you have i think like sparkling water is
probably of the utmost importance that
day because i'll be like super
dehydrated the one that i always have
but you know i'd like to indulge in like
a little diet pepsi oh okay i didn't
place that order okay okay
um and then let's move on to dessert
because i don't know i'm just throwing
it out there
a caramel cake
i'm just throwing it out there it could
be a small personal size one
do you think we can make that work
because like this is a special meal and
i'm not really into like the
traditionally jewish desserts like how
many times can we have regular you know
yeah yeah except olivia got those bobcat
bites that i wouldn't mind eating again
they were so good but for me at yom
kippur the dessert is a cinnamon raisin
bagel with biscoff cookie butter on top
and a little jelly no doesn't that just
sound like something i'm so excited like
i think i'm gonna have a bagel today for
lunch and today's like my last day on
earth so what are you having for dinner
i don't know and like ben's going to
shul so like i have to eat by myself
could i entice you to some
homemade popper deli handmade pepper
deli handmade popper deli
robert
handmade pepper deli that i made at home
no i need something from a restaurant
like it tasted restaurant quality i'm
sure it did but i need i'm thinking
either like a seraphina moment
or
oh my god i'm so nervous i can't believe
like the day is upon us we talk about it
all year long and it's like literally
tomorrow and i am looking forward here
for yom kippur
did you see the new
i didn't oh i saw it on instagram the
new sunday night football they used the
new mandalorian technology it was
looking really good it wasn't brown's
first jets
but it was good they don't copy and
paste like the songs like the teams
anymore no they do but when we were
going through it like it wasn't it
wasn't this particular game that wasn't
the particular game but
no and i found out thank you for
everyone for letting me know she records
every combination i thought she recorded
every
team name in each trope and they put
them together
but she records every game that's going
to happen she sits there and she records
i'd love to sit in on that session not
all heroes wear capes you guys but
actually carrie underwood does yeah um
so yeah like i'm looking forward to
feeling lighter like on friday i feel
like i'm gonna have like a renewed sense
of
energy and i've just been feeling kind
of heavy this last week because it's
that's what you're supposed to do just
reflect and when i reflect and i look
inside and i see me for what i truly am
which is ugly
it doesn't make me feel good so i'm
looking forward to rolling my eyes the
forward way looking forward after yom
kippur and focusing on other people's
problems not mine great okay well it
sounds like you have a plan
and obviously that means there will be
no show tomorrow but just know we will
be repenting and finished and wishing we
were at the show wishing yeah except i'm
looking forward to sleeping in a little
yeah me too i've been sleeping good this
week like some good pregnancy sleep oh
that's thank you for reminding me i
wanted to tell you
if you come near me like i
smell today
i had the craziest night of like tossing
turning waking up for some reason
drenched in sweat and i woke up because
i was so exhausted i woke up so late i
should have taken like a body shower
because like i was just like i was
literally doing the marathon in my sleep
like an elliptical i reek
okay
just a word to the wise thanks for the
heads up
what do you think was keeping you up
um i don't know because i can't remember
my dreams but i fell asleep really fast
i was having deep like psychological
dreams he was a psychological thriller
literally
and that's where i'm at okay well i
think we should get into everything
because we've got a lot to do today and
we've got a lot to talk about so without
further ado who's here don't worry about
him it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode of the morning toast
is brought to you by liquid iv liquid iv
hydrates you faster and more efficiently
than water alone they contain five
essential vitamins it has more vitamin c
than an orange and as much potassium as
a banana they are healthier than sugary
sports drink and they have no artificial
flavors preservatives and they're made
with less sugar than an apple so liquid
iv is so effective because of their
cellular transport technology if you
have a hard time drinking water which i
do it's so hard liquid i've eat comes in
a ton of flavors you add it to your
bottle of water and first of all it
tastes so much better and second of all
it hydrates you like three times more so
it's really really um a fabulous product
and you didn't hear it from me but i've
they're known to help with a hangover
and every now and then so uh check it
out they're also on a mission to change
the world the company is donating four
million servings in response to covet 19
and products are being donated to
hospitals first responders food banks
veterans and active military grab your
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use the code toast at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today using promo code toast at liquid
iv.com by the way before we dive into
the stories can you tell everyone about
your experience watching lularoe yes i
was going to wait till the end of the
show for a content segment oh okay so
well let's do that but i
don't do that i like that i do okay cool
cool our first story big news time 100
most influential people list is out and
megan and harry are on the cover there's
a lot of other influential people inside
but um chef jose andrus wrote a short
essay about the pair you know how
everybody like writes about someone else
just like jlo wrote about charlie as we
saw on hulu well so i feel like i'm
looking at this with a whole new
perspective after watching the demilio
show um and i just think it's like kind
of funny how like 16 year old charlie
dimelio had the wherewithal
excuse me
excuse me
that's problematic
no i mean we're not gonna cut the show
we'll just
have to ride it out if you see someone
say something
yeah hold on
[Music]
you see anyone yeah
oh did they lock us in
this doesn't open i can't believe it
uh
10 51 11 30. 11 30.
11 12 11
uh
how do you say 20
yes
we got time you guys
okay
so
we're if you're watching on youtube
you're getting the uncut footage but if
you're on um
podcast it's like we never left so now
after watching the demilio show i feel
like i have a whole new perspective on
this
list and i just find it interesting this
is not me being a hater but probably is
me being a hater i do find it
interesting how 16 year old charlie
demilio had the wherewithal you know
like not to make it about herself you
know there's like
real activists and doctors and
scientists doing amazing work and she
didn't want to you know she was honored
to be on the list but she didn't want to
like make it about herself and then
harry and megan just waltz right on the
cover i just want to say i think it's a
different list because they were saying
it was like an inspiring list like no it
was influence it was influenced yeah but
it was a different time of year and then
like that was filmed at the beginning of
this year
i don't know i don't know if it's the
exact same list okay that's all i say
i just like that that is an interesting
point i mean
yeah i don't want to be a hater megan
and harry are you know megan and harry i
and there are a lot of things and
they're you know so high profile and
like everything they do is news i don't
know that i would say that they're so
influential that's what i was going to
say as well they're
a-list and they're
incredibly recognizable like they have a
podcast have any of you listen to it
they have a children's book have any of
you purchased it i know and he has a
show on apple plus has any of you
watching i'm not saying nobody's
watching it but i'm i'm just saying like
i i don't know people who are like
thoroughly influenced by them or like
they're the number one most influential
like on the cover no i completely agree
and honestly if they were buried
somewhere down there i wouldn't really
think about it i'd be like yeah they're
big yeah sure because there's a lot of
people on the list i'm not going to go
through how influential every single one
of them is did the show even come out
yet i've heard not a a lick about it i
think that it did come out no you're
right like their podcast launched and
then everyone was like oh my god and
then nobody cared ever like it's just
like a lot of hoopla for everything they
do yeah and nobody really like follows
through except for with the oprah
interview because like that was right
but then it's like okay that's not the
most interesting thing about them is
that they're royal defects right and if
they're not talking about the royal
family like are people listening right
no so i agree then they go back to
talking about the royal family and it's
like all you do is talk about the royal
family right so like is this the list of
like famous people who else is on the
list okay it's a really long list
there's obviously the different
categories so we'll go through um
relevant categories and
people so we have what is this one oh
icons is one naomi osaka very
influential
alexei navalny
oh
megan mccain's always tweeting about him
but it seems influential britney spears
very influential
um
dolly parton
oh moderna yeah yeah and then there's a
lot of other people but i'm just going
through like celebrities
then in the pioneers category we have
billy eilish
incredibly influential suny lee
i'm happy she's there me too when i
think i i guess yeah no she actually
inspire she's very inspiring her story
i take yep she's influential in the
titans category we have simone biles i'm
extremely influential she honestly
should have been on the cover if we're
being honest tim cook
sure yeah
shonda rhimes of course tom brady yeah
yeah then there seems like there's a lot
of people who feel like they would be on
it every year like elon musk is on this
list well yeah he's influencing every
year no constantly raising the bar for
all of us artists so that's really like
the celebrity category kate winslet
that's incredibly bizarre
but i guess her show mayor of east town
oh influenced this year that's true okay
okay still pretty random yeah bad bunny
100 sure chloe zao
i don't know who that is jason sudeikis
he's having a moment well ted lasso and
then i think maybe they just put him on
this list because they feel bad for him
because of olivia wilde wouldn't you
isn't he dating someone though yeah like
a model you know child you know okay
scarlett johansson
um i think like with black widow and
i guess yeah that's definitely a stretch
i think i know but like there are so
many celebrities walking this earth and
like these just don't feel like the
biggest ones to me but in terms of
influence yeah is this a list of the
most famous people here's more like lil
nas yes a hundred percent bow and yang
your fave oh and he's influencing snl
and by the way he's doing such important
work like bringing snl into the 21st
century yeah tracy ellis ross yes
blackish is huge daniel kaluuya
yes
kane brown
yes yes so that's um there's other
people in the category but those are
like the most famous people
um then there's a bunch of leaders who
are politicians then
um innovators so that's like elon musk
and other innovators who i don't
recognize um
and that seems to be the list yeah so
honestly like i would love some i feel
like we say this when we report on this
list a lot like
what is the point of this list like
because honestly like
if it's a roundup of famous people then
yes harry and megan were probably the
most famous thing the biggest deal to
happen this in the last you know in 2021
like who else would you put on the cover
right but if we're talking about
influence like you're right like all the
all these deals they keep getting like
it's huge news like she's got a voice
over for disney plus and then it's like
nobody cares yeah so all these projects
are huge headlines and then in actuality
does anybody actually care about the
content they're making i don't think
anyone listens to their podcast
yeah i don't even know if they're still
doing the podcast right now right so in
terms of influence in the way that we
understand influence in this day and age
harry and megan are not influential but
they're really famous
yes i agree now i'm looking to see who's
been on other covers yeah oh then there
in 2019 it was um there was three covers
dwayne johnson taylor swift sandra oh oh
i remember that yeah yeah i felt
strongly well actually it looks like
there was like a bunch of covers but
that's just one okay like 2018. like
honestly charlie should have been on the
cover no cause that's what i'm saying
like if we're talking about modern
influence
or like i don't know someone who had a
you know an amazing scientific
breakthrough for you know the cure for
cancer i don't know like yeah
i'm just i'm just struggling to
understand what and who harry and megan
influenced this year or just like in
general yeah maybe like the american
public about vita what the royal family
did to them i don't know like i'm not
understanding the influence right i'm
not under the influence i'm not under
the influence either but it's so hard to
get me under there but once i am oh i'm
sold true i'm buying leggings you guys
jackie we're going to discuss it in the
tv recap jackie has the most interesting
take on the lularoe lularoe you keep
calling it lularoe so now if i was you
i'd wanna wear lularoe i'd wanna wear
lularoe i'd wanna wear lularoe
by the way it sounds better if it's lulu
i know but that was a song from the
documentary anyways um that's time 100
check it out or don't it is what it is
or don't like nobody cares and it's also
aware that like there's a like the list
is
called the influential list and like
being an influencer is actually a job
right and there are people on this earth
who are influencers who are influential
who are not on this list like where is
even just one podcaster one influencer
like rogan
kiara frogni joe rogan yeah
that's actually really weird yeah
because if we're talking about influence
like people like i remember when
i was watching some episode like
i forget who it was whatever like maybe
it's bernie sanders like people because
of joe rogan like his numbers went up
like tenfold like that's actual
influence yes yes that's actual
influence i guess the podcasters on this
list are megan and harry oh thank you so
much for correcting me i stand corrected
yeah no that is really weird or even
influencers like just one even yeah
like honestly something navy is really
influential like her business is blowing
up rach parcell
honestly like just on my personal time
100 rage parcels on the cover oh my god
we should do like a patreon episode of
our personal time 100 people who are
actually influential influences me to
buy things and like think about
something that also just launches like a
really interesting conversation about
influencers because
and this is like my favorite thing to
talk about because you could be an
influencer with like millions of
followers and have no influence yeah you
could start your own line of clothing
and you could have
no customers or you could be like a an
instagram influencer with like 400 000
followers i feel like shannon ford is
like the most influential
like person on instagram and she doesn't
have
multi-millions so it's not even about
followers it's really about influence
and not everyone has that it's so true
and like i could i could but i won't
like rattle off people who have no
influence but just now i have like a
list in my head well we should do a
patreon episode about our time our toast
100 most influential
totally totally toastly
okay next up switching gears comedians
are reacting to the tragic death of snl
star norm mcdonald
nor mcdonald's unexpected death from
cancer at the age of 61 has brought an
outpouring of remembrances from fellow
comics and actors on social media from
jim carrey patton oswalt seth rogen jim
gaffigan everybody's talking about norm
he um
was struggling privately with a
nine-year battle with cancer oh i didn't
know that yes and he passed away
well now that he's in the news like my i
was getting like things on tick tock um
of him and it made me want to watch his
episode of comedians in cars oh for sure
because there was like this really quick
clip with him and jerry talking about
bill cosby and it's very you know
not appropriate but it was
so funny oh that's so funny i was seeing
like a bunch of like quotes of his going
around or like video clips from like his
time on snl and other stuff and it
definitely like that sounds like a great
episode to watch to get to know the man
a bit better and then it got me thinking
like when is the next season of
comedians and cars
it's been a while
and
yeah i mean comedy is more personal than
food so these things take time
i mean if you don't make the rules you
need to i don't make the rules no jerry
is told he has to say it once per
episode or he won't be able to do the
show or he won't get paid or he won't
get paid yeah what's your favorite
episode of comedians in cars
oh i don't i haven't watched as many as
you have okay
well i'm very selective like if i don't
know the person
i will watch the episode yeah i have to
think of just the episodes that i have
watched but i do feel like there's like
a
an obvious answer that i just can't i
think can i say it for you i think i
know what you're it's tracy morgan oh
that is a great it's really good so is
the jim gaffigan one yeah
but you're such a jim gaffigan girly i
am
you know i met him once on a plane kevin
hart is also really good oh yeah and
he's a fave of mine yeah and dave
chappelle did one too but it was kind of
serious
yeah
also the steve harvey one yeah
oh yes
you forget that like especially like
steve harvey who's done so much he
started in comedy but now i just assume
i think of him as like you know the guy
who announced the wrong miss universe
like right he's so many other things
family feud the steve harvey show but he
started in stand up and he is so funny
and the kate mckinnon one is really
funny too yes it is
honestly most of them are funny honestly
i could go back and watch them like i
feel like it's been so long but he like
did all the comedians yeah the larry
david one is interesting because they're
both trying to like out larry each other
it's a larry off they have like the same
like dry no because like he's seinfeld
because of like the seinfeld is larry
and larry is larry so they're both like
competing like talking about like how
comedies
have you been seeing like harry not
harry larry has been like out and about
he went to the us open oh he meant
fashion week and he went to the u.s open
and was like plugging his ears because
it was so loud it was like so larry and
it just got me thinking like where's the
season yeah they keep saying that you
know curb it's the final season and then
there's another season well because
moronic [ __ ] keeps happening in the
world like how could larry not do a
season on covid like yeah it's his dream
to stay in the house yeah
loved it well it hasn't come out yet but
i will love it i know i will for sure
okay ready for our next story which is a
little like met gala follow-up some
things have like emerged not a lot but
one justin bieber and hailey baldwin
were taunted with a selena chan at the
met gala okay
yes and i feel like i've went on a rant
before about like people who like
literally are mourning the loss of a
relationship that wasn't theirs from
five years ago yeah and how i just want
to say i think they're enormous losers i
think so basically they got out of the
car they walked onto the carpet and
people were across the street like
lining up for days and they were just
chanting selena selena when justin and
haley are trying to take photos right
and
i just want to let you know like if you
were there and you participated in the
chant just know like i
hate you not even because like i'm a
haley stan versus selena like you're a
grown person if you're old enough to get
like get yourself to the metropolitan
museum of art
you know like you're probably not there
with your parents and you probably came
with your friends like you're mature
enough to travel in the city by yourself
and you're chanting about selena gomez
to another couple who's very happily in
love married
you are a loser and you should reflect
look inside yourself and be like why
it's it's you know it's right before you
yom kippur you should ask god god why am
i such a loser
maybe he could help you because we can't
and it's also never too late to change
you know and it's a new year it's a new
leaf you can repent for chanting selena
at the met gala and you can move forward
you have to stop but for real you just
can't keep doing it no and then it's
like people will like take clips of them
on the red carpet looking uncomfortable
and be like oh my god he's thinking of
selena no you're making them so
uncomfortable stop so they're red carpet
body language we were talking about it
yesterday but not on the show and now i
guess it makes a little bit more sense
but first of all i do think that like
you know posing for pictures
can be awkward there were a few moments
that like people were talking about
first he put his hand on her stomach and
then she swatted it away because she
knew everyone was gonna say that they're
pregnant and i don't think that they are
whatsoever but they're both like
laughing once she realized like what it
looks like yep then they also like
switch sides because she wanted to be on
her good side right like they're so
relatable but what's also so funny is
like you watch a 10 second clip of them
taking pictures and it's like pretty
awkward and then you see the pictures
and it's like
movie star movie star so they know what
they're doing movie moment but it's just
like so that's how just
i just don't know how haley does it like
these accounts like you look at her
instagram comments just like saying that
like shut up
and honestly if you're there to
represent selena you're making selena
look like an enormous loser like is she
still thinking about justin is that what
you're saying justin's happily married
and she's not and she's thinking about
like you're making your girl who you're
there to defend you're making her look
like a loser in this situation so you
should stop
send this to a jelena fan this episode
because you guys are [ __ ] losers i'm
sorry stop we are grown people like stop
and honestly when i saw those videos of
everyone chanting and like them getting
out of the car like i was so sad for
them yeah
and if you think like selena's the
victim in all this you acting this way
you're making justin and haley the
victim so you're having the adverse
effect and you're stupid
thank you claudia thank you for this psa
really pissed me off the other thing i
want to talk about the met gal because
kim posted on her instagram about her
dressing you know every all day people
were like speculating about the meaning
and talking about you know how they how
it made them feel and she posted on
instagram like what's more american than
a t-shirt so yeah like perhaps that was
the
reference right people look people have
been giving like scientific historic
footnotes
a bibliography yeah on what they thought
this meant and and like literally giving
dissertations and she's like it's a
t-shirt like is that it is it an f sure
like that's it
we all have been spinning our wheels
like it's just
just a t-shirt it was just because of
t-shirt material which is a classic
american and she was wearing like a big
t-shirt
because of t-shirt
yeah not z-shirt
not a t-shirt
no i was like honestly
like crushed
like is that is that okay to say
yeah but it also made me feel like
because at some points i'm feeling like
i have no artistic vision like and i
love kim and i'm ready i'm embracing
the meaning and the impact to wash over
me i was watching daily pop yesterday
because i wanted to see what they said
about met gala looks and you know when
you see a picture of a look so many
times especially like some of the
fabulous pictures that emerge from the
red carpet
my opinion does start to change and i
want to take back one thing i said
yesterday about a look
i don't hate jlo's hat anymore oh okay
seeing it from enough angles
i can appreciate the hat and i hope she
had a great evening as mrs hat okay
so then they were talking about kim's
look and they're showing it from all
these different angles and they were
like this look is stunning
and i was just like what am i missing
right you know how how does she look
stunning they said she looks stunning
bro you can't even see your face
so
maybe i just have you know limitations
when it comes to understanding art which
is very possible i'm not an art girly
i'm not no and by the way i can admit
what i know and what i don't know and
like i don't understand art like at all
and to be honest i'm not even interested
in understanding it yeah maybe like one
day maybe that's just like something
that comes with age maybe that's like
the next stop for me on like my
interests in life to become like an art
person
honestly
now i have no
okay i just had another thought about
the outfit okay another theory
maybe just hear me out it's so
outrageous but it's also like so
recognizable nobody's ever worn anything
like that ever again maybe kim's hoping
like in 50 years
when the theme for met gala again is
like you know americana someone will go
as her thus cementing herself as a
permanent important figure in american
fashion and you think that she wasn't
that before
even though another interpretation of
yours says that she dressed as her own
body because she's such an important
figure okay excuse me
defensive i didn't say interpretation of
mine i said i saw it on technical but i
liked it so did i but i was just
thinking like this is another
possibility because like maybe she wants
to be like an audrey hepburn because
like audrey hepburn had all these iconic
looks and this one is like so
recognizable
yeah
i hope that's not it but you know
they're all
possible i still don't maybe it's or
maybe it's just a t-shirt
which was just really disappointing to
me it also made me feel like better that
okay at least there wasn't like this
larger meaning that i didn't understand
that we missed out yeah
okay moving on are you ready for our
next story only if it's next story
that's brought to you by jenny kane
yes it is
you guys follow us around the corner and
if you have no clothing listen up
because nobody does fall like jenny kane
no it's the sweater you can't wait to
wear the mules you'll be pairing with
everything so the mules are their
signature piece they come in leather
suede shearling and more and it's the
classic shoe that started it all they're
effortless super comfortable and they
come
in endless versatility and they really
just make you
look very put together if you're just
wearing a simple outfit also i would say
like some of my favorite sweaters that i
have are from jenny kane they have the
fisherman which is the classic cashmere
knit and the cocoon which is a cardigan
and it also comes in a crew neck
it's their best selling sweater style we
can't get enough of it it has a relaxed
fit and an ultra cozy silhouette jenny
kane believes that getting dressed
should be the easiest part of your
routine with polished basics that will
never go out of style they make everyday
moments a breeze that's what you need
for fall like a couple really good
staples that you can dress up dress down
and jenny kane has them whether they're
sweaters or shoes cardigans it's really
important just to have like five or six
things that you can wear multiple times
but they look super different and
they're all really good quality
they're elevated basics that focus on
comfort without sacrificing style
find your forever pieces at
jennycaine.com and get 15 off your first
order when you use code toast at
checkout that's j-e-n-n-i
k-a-y-n-e
dot com promo code toast
thank you claudia our next story is
really interesting some reboot news the
proud family revival sets lizzo tiffany
haddish lil na's x and more as guest
stars disney plus has set a stacked cast
literally so stacked of guest stars and
new recurring talent for the proud
family revival it's called louder and
prouder in commerce
great name and commemoration of the
original animated series is 20th
anniversary the guest starring voice
cast for the series set to launch on
disney plus in 2022 will feature
a-listers from the worlds of music film
tv and sports including lizzo lil nas x
chance the rapper normani leslie odom jr
jr tiffany haddish lena waith anthony
anderson gabrielle union debbie allen
there's literally so many names here i'm
just going to highlight a few more jane
lynch marseille martin jane lynch gabby
douglas oh
brenda song lori hernandez so it's uh
jayden smith there's so many it's not a
um
reboot it's a reunion of sorts like it's
a series oh like so i think it's
some sort of reboot revival
do you think they're gonna reboot the
episode where she goes on oprah where
she puts her foot in it i mean there are
so many guest stars here and ober was
not mentioned which that just definitely
worries me proud that money will push
your buttons
i don't know how it goes after that um
no i really do hope that sugar mama puts
her foot in it once again and maybe they
just didn't want to put it on the flyer
but oprah's definitely making a surprise
appearance right i just wonder if like
for me like that
that reference just like every time i'm
cooking i'm like i'm gonna put my foot
in it like i just i'm always thinking
about like i and i know no sugar mama
lives rent-free in your mind she really
does for anyone else just do you think
about that what that like is all the
time never no you don't because when i
mentioned it to you you didn't know what
i was talking about what it was but like
i just wonder if other people
are just always like thinking about
sugar mama putting her foot in it it's
very possible and to be honest i'm very
skeptical of reboots
um and just like any sort of revivals
but i really feel like
if something is being taken care of by
disney
disney care so much about keeping the
integrity of their stories
and that's why the cruella was so good
it wasn't just like a strewn together
prequel or sequel they care so much
about the integrity of the light and the
legacy of the stories they've created
over the years that they're not gonna
they're not gonna [ __ ] this up like and
i have the utmost faith if something's
on disney plus like i feel really good
about it i do agree with you
so i think that this won't be
terrible i think will be really fun for
you know the
90s kids and all of us
and we'll see what they do with it yeah
so far it has the makings of a good
reboot i mean you know i'm i am
anti-reboot generally speaking right but
this sounds like an anniversary special
like it's and
has disney plus done any
reboots reboots or reunions like when i
think of reboots i think of like fuller
house
which is netflix i think of friends
which was hbo max
i don't really feel like there's been
like a
big reboot reunion special
on disney plus no not that i've seen and
i think if anyone can do it i have so
much faith in bob iger even though i
don't even think he works at the company
anymore but he'll always be my ceo oh
nothing but respect for my ceo honestly
i need to buy his master class like you
should i could learn something you
should i have a master class code for
you when people ask like who is like
your business like idol
i had never i mean no one's ever asked
me that but like i just have a feeling
that maybe they would
who would you my business idol would
probably be kim
yeah kardashian
mine like would probably be brian kelly
that's a good one he's so rich yeah
so is kim though yeah are you ready for
a fifth and final story it's a little
more tv news but
i'm sorry
did you say
the final story
[Music]
little story
[Applause]
ah that felt good yeah really you just
need to take it out on the triangle
literally okay julianne huff is
addressing the activist show backlash
and past blackface costume julian huff
has released a lengthy statement
addressing the backlash that has
surrounded her recently announced cbs
cbs competition show the activist which
pits teams of activists against each
other in challenges and uses their
online engagement and celebrity judges
sorry start again i i need a better
understanding about the show
it's a competition show for activists
for activists so everyone
who thought that was a good idea
no i mean people thought it was a good
idea it clearly you know
it got julianne huff as a uh co-host
alongside usher and priyanka chopra the
show was like announced last week and
you know
not to no i'm i need to go read the
tweets i'm sure they're so funny like
people already think like social media
activism is so performative like yeah
you're literally just giving so much
credibility to those okay so explain the
show
eight pits teams of activists they're
pitting activists against each other in
challenges and it uses their online
engagement and celebrity judges to
determine an overall winner
so
there was a lot of backlash for the
concept about the show and then uh
julianne huff right and she said now she
admits she's not qualified to be judging
a show about activism the premise of
which has been widely panned online so i
think everything about this
formula is just a no i also read a
series of tweets from someone who
auditioned to be on the show oh an
activist and he said like the whole
process was so demoralizing like like
the the things that they wanted him to
talk about like they just want him to
cry like you're lying like instead of
like i i can't explain it well but it
was just i don't even know if he wound
up on the show but just the way that the
producers were like trying to get these
actors to trigger them to activate
was all wrong no this is such a bad idea
like just
even as like a premise like because when
you're describing the show it kind of
reminds me of celebrity apprentice like
all these people getting together to
like raise money like for a cause but
like those were famous people doing it
and like it was somewhat interesting
when they did it i don't understand like
from an entertainment perspective like
who thought this show would be like fun
to watch like it's like sad
and
the julianne huff of it all like i don't
know how she could sign on to the show
not thinking
that her 2013 blackface would resurface
and honestly
for like doing blackface is such a big
deal like it's atrocious she really
never got like it was like a big deal
but it was like when it happened right
she didn't get like this huge cancel
like when i like when i think of like
how okay here's a good example like
megan kelly like got fired for like kind
of defending blackface and just say like
but as if it's a costume like it was
like a
she didn't do black faces in
it was in conversation
and like when you think of like megan
kelly versus julian have julian huff is
like an a-lister you know and like megan
kelly like has a youtube channel you
know yeah yeah so i don't know like who
on her team advised her that this would
be a good idea of course her past
indiscretions would become a topic of
conversation and honestly i feel like
now
she might go through like a cycle of
cancellation yes and also
even if this show were a good idea
activists at activating activating and
competing with other activists say like
that premise didn't bother people like
the judges should be activists like who
can give such a good call who can like
you know famous activists who could like
give critique about like how to activate
or what you're doing like not just
celebrities telling these activists what
to do with their life right like
technically
the activists could teach the celebrity
a thing or two not vice versa right and
and i don't even think the host should
be or judges should be uh celebrities
who also happen to be active no it
should be like activists by day
and activists by night yes like not
celebrities famous activists
i'd have to think about who you are
gloria steinem
sure okay yeah like that yeah but no i
com that's by the way that's another
element of why this is moroni so i just
think across the board from beginning to
end everything about this show has
rubbed people completely the wrong way i
don't know if the show is even going to
air it really shouldn't even though i
can't lie like i might tune in just to
see how stupid it is like yeah no and
it's just so embarrassing like for
everyone it is and i just think like
this show and i guess they they filmed
episodes so so it's coming
it's set to premiere on october 22nd on
cbs and paramount plus you guys i don't
think it's going to make it to october
22nd no and you know what this is just
like another example it's kind of like
the imagine video i was thinking the
same thing this is like
people in hollywood like really thinking
they're doing something and that like
they can teach us like how to be good
too and it's like
you think you're helping and like we us
normies like we see you for what you
truly are which is oh good like
they just think they're really doing
something and like we're just gonna eat
it all up and like we're just looking at
them like you guys really think like
you're everything of the sort do you
know how many people had to
work on this show approve this show a
green light the show produced a show and
nobody thought like is this out of touch
not one person said that
moronic yeah
beyond beyond so the countdown is on
until october 22nd julianne huff
releases like this long statement on her
instagram
and properly acknowledging like all of
it the moronic nature of this journey
yes i don't think the show will air no i
don't think it will either i don't think
it should it's one of those things that
will just like but then justice for the
activists who like thought they were
getting their big break you know
yeah but it also sounds like from the
activist perspective it was nothing of
the sort right you know and like they're
like why can't all activists like do
what they want to do why can they why
has their they're only to be one
activity wait like why are we ranking
activists the activists it doesn't say
like it's not so called activism it's
not the show isn't called i think we're
all
activists honestly activist is just one
of those words that you say too many
times whereas we've said it too many
times and now i'm like it's gibberish
it's like
activity i feel that way about the word
garage i know you do so does the viewers
[Laughter]
i'm sorry it's fine
let's jump into the tv recap which is
brought to you by oh bruce what is the
light the best electric tubes
the best electric toothbrush on the
market you guys okay some electric
toothbrush can cost over two hundred
dollars which is just unreasonable but
bruce is a the best one out there and b
super affordable and they're like
styling while and living it up in the
city because you're in your mouth
literally so the brush itself is very
high tech high power it comes with six
unique modes to customize your brushing
experience it has a four week battery
life a magnetic charging stand and a
compact travel case they also offer
subscription programs never forget to
change your brush head again bruce will
ship you a new replacement head every
six months so you're never stuck using a
worn down brush head the design is very
sleek their electric toothbrush has a
modern aesthetically pleasing design and
it comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter and every time they drop their
like new season of colors it's like it's
like when apple does their you know
quarterly drops like new iphone it's
like such a big deal so if you want to
get 15 off your bruce toothbrush kit and
the refill plan use promo code toast at
bruce.com that's 15 off using promo code
toast at brush.com
thank you claudia okay tell me tell
everyone because i know about where i'm
at with lularoe what episode are you on
and what are you feeling i just finished
episode three where one of the
consultants said i looked into hiring a
class action lawyer got it so i have one
episode left and i think that's really
where all the [ __ ] hits the fans so i'm
sure everything i say today i will
totally reject after watching the fourth
episode where i see like what was going
on the air of their ways but do you i by
the way do you feel like it took them a
little too long in the documentary to
explain like what was up
like what's the problem i still don't
understand the problem really like i see
that there's like faulty um leggings
leggings and stuff but then you know and
some of the people in the documentary
were those who experienced the faulty
leggings but then you also have the
owner i forgot his name diane's
and mark mark and he was and he's like
saying that those were
not
that those were very small
percentages of how whatever but i also
but i don't understand like so if all of
them it wasn't
it wasn't because at one point they had
to
pay people back for the shitty inventory
they sold and they spent over 50 million
dollars paying people back so it was a
lot of people okay so that i will that i
will learn in the fourth episode yeah
but
what i don't understand is like why did
the quality all of a sudden get so
terrible i mean obviously they were just
two
hillbillies running a billion dollar
company like they had no experience they
hired high-level people their nephews
and their sons they didn't know and by
the way their growth was unbelievable
and if they had stayed i think at like
fifteen thousand retailers they could
have been successful even fifty thousand
but a hundred thousand no that and all
that requires like c suite level people
a ceo right but then also at a certain
point there is a cap to how many
retailers you can have even if you have
bob iger running your business right
because then there's a woman there's
seven other women in her town who are
selling lularoe and like everybody's got
their leggings like there is it you do
max out so i think they reach that point
where also like the inventory but they
didn't care because they were then a
business that was only dependent on how
many retailers they had nobody was even
selling [ __ ] like over 70
of their retailers were making no money
like their business and that's why it
was an illegal pyramid scheme their
business had nothing to do with how many
leggings the retailer sold because the
retailers had to buy for mark and diane
okay but the retailers were selling the
leggings at least in the beginning like
you know the people they got on
the documentary
are the women who had success had
success like out of the hundred thousand
they said like less than one percent
were making like six figures yes that i
saw and then like so point zero one
percent were made um
we're getting those bonus checks the
other 70
were not because they didn't have people
below them they just had leggings to
sell and that's like but fundamentally
why a pyramid scheme is illegal okay but
like in the beginning when one of the
women like she does her first legging
party and she comes home with like
fourteen hundred dollars why can't
someone at the bottom of the tier do
that
because that's just not how that's like
pyramid schemes are designed to keep 80
of the retailers losing money or making
no money that's like that's what that
guy was explaining that's why they're
illegal
unless you're like a mentor and you get
up to like a when you're just like a the
bottom level of the like if you were
just selling leggings
there's no money to be made very little
especially when you have to pay so much
for
the
the [ __ ] yeah
anyways okay so talking about the the
that end of it which is what i'm about
to get into and i'm sure i will you know
but understanding yes i know you're in
the beginning like and with all of the
like marketing that we're doing and like
all the ways it changed like so many
women's lives for the better for a very
long time before it all turned sour i'm
just like i'm i'm ready to shop lularoe
like no i know it was actually really
sad they also the way that they describe
these leggings like i do want to try
them and i saw someone commented
yesterday like you get them in black you
were making fun of leggings but that's
just because you haven't tried them yet
apparently they are just like magic yeah
um so like that's pretty enticing to me
but also just like this
in the beginning like the fact that like
women could stay at home and then also
have this little shop and you know
full-time income for part-time work etc
etc but then it's clear that like the
execution no and execution we can all
agree [ __ ] they
moldy smelly i don't want that [ __ ] in
my house yeah i'm quitting yeah
but the message started to change too
and it was not no longer about this is
part-time work first of all you're not
working hard enough if you're not
working full-time right and second of
all your husband should quit his job and
work on that take on the real
responsibilities while you just like
make videos no but also he should be
invested in lularoe too that way you can
never exit because at so many points i'm
like watching this thing and i'm like
okay things started to feel weird you
know maybe you took your money you get
out right it's good when your whole
family and that's why the woman at the
end who like literally has to go into
bankruptcy and gets divorced it's
because
i haven't gotten to her their whole life
is dependent on this company that lets
them down right and it's clear that like
from the top down like that was what was
encouraged when that was not the bill of
goods that was sold at the beginning
right so in the beginning this
is this idea and also like to deanne's
credit like it sounds like from her
story she started about in a natural way
she was you know she went to the swap
meet and she saw these dresses she sold
them for a little more she made skirts
in her kitchen everybody liked them one
of her friends wanted to sell them and
it really like the pyramid started in
just like a word of mouth like she likes
making clothes and selling like in a
very industrious
strap on your boots sort of way i know
but by the end of the documentary i'm
like can i believe anything these people
say like they become so delusional
and it's like at first when i'm watching
i'm like these people are so sweet like
they just want to help stay-at-home moms
and like i do believe like that their
intention in the beginning was not to
[ __ ] over millions of people
but by the end of the documentary like
you really don't know what to believe
like the best thing is like
he the the
says to diane like what what made you
want to start a brand that like empowers
women and like what does it mean to be
women speaks over her and he's like
actually you know dan can i take this
one yeah like it was so funny so i just
don't know but
like my my feelings at the end were like
i thought it was like so earnest and
sweet in the beginning but like these
people are like
like delusional okay so being delusional
isn't a crime no but stealing money from
people is
we'll get there i'm not there okay so
i'm just saying so with the moldy
leggings they like refused to buy it
back from people and people would spend
ten thousand dollars on their you know
startup fees to get moldy leggings yeah
yeah no no no i i get that like but i
can't get into why the leggings were
moldy but they just because they were
leaving them outside
they just they just lost control of the
whole thing like they're like once they
started growing like they should have
been like acquired by someone or
put a ceo in who has like fortune 500
experience two people with no business
experience besides selling clothing
cannot run a billion dollar company they
just can't yeah with their kids
with also a hundred thousand essentially
contractors right like let's say you're
a restaurant they had a hundred thousand
stores
yeah but like all those retailers are
people with personalities and like
things you know it's it's a complex
organism that they're dealing with yes
so i agree with that but i also think
that no matter who was running it it was
gonna get too big but the way that it
just blew up like it was just it was
crazy crazy i had and it's just so crazy
i never heard of it i know but i guess
like i was like in college or right just
not in the mlm space no not in the mlm
space um
so it was it's very interesting
and they're just characters like
diane and mark yeah so i will
finish it
i just yeah i want to see where a lot of
the people women who are speaking right
now like where they ended up like if any
of them were able to be like you know
what this is just getting to be too
all-consuming like i'm going to take my
wins and just watch yeah they have like
five people who have any different
things okay
like i hope that there were people out
of the hundred thousand or even the you
know mentors trainers who made good
money and at a certain point realized
like i'm gonna
check out i'm gonna step away there's
one girl like that okay and she's the
one who like was like top she was a
third retailer she's like the top
employee at the company
step back not because she had a bad
experience or was not making money but
she it just didn't feel right that like
literally 90 like 90 000 people were
making no money and she was yeah and
there's actually a woman and you'll
figure out which one it is who still
sells for lularoe
well there's one woman talking about how
she wants to keep selling lularoe like
forever and how she's working on her
sixth cruise yeah she's talking about
that throughout the documentary which
also makes me feel like
well people are still doing it they're
still in business i just looked at their
instagram the other day and all the
comments are like flooded obviously like
great documentary but they're still in
business i don't get it
well we'll see i'll i have to watch the
fourth episode i just i was really on
the journey with with this with this
brand no because it really like for a
while like was this like female
empowerment like machine even if like
her brand of female empowerment was like
you know traditional traditional yes
and also like empowering women like
within the home i still can't leave the
home no totally but by the way there are
a lot of people in our country who do
that right no but and also those women
had already made the choice to stay at
home like it wasn't like she was forcing
them to stay home when they wanted to
like enter the workplace so she was
giving them something to do so i
i don't hate all of that um definitely
like want to go to a tupperware party
soon um but it then it definitely turns
toxic and the stuff with like the weight
loss surgery so weird but then it also
feels like these women were so close
like it's clear that if you were in this
like if you were in diane's inner circle
like right the chat like the little
like lularoe was your whole life you
know and so if one friend it's just like
you know if you're in a friend group and
one friend goes and gets this bracelet
like yeah you know where it doesn't stop
at leggings no and so
on the one hand it's like okay she's
their boss and she's like kind of
convincing weight loss surgery like
that's incredibly [ __ ] up but on the
other hand when like you're in like a
circle and this
thing is your whole life
for better or for worse you get like
influence oh my god you look amazing
what'd you do oh okay i'll do it even if
it's just like a facial right or
whatever no i feel that you know yeah
everything
everything with lularoe is the extreme
yeah and when it's with your work it
borders on inappropriate and
unprofessional right but they like
because it's not a workplace it's your
whole life right yes so there's just
blurred lines everywhere it's an
interesting documentary just because
it's the most bizarre story ever
yeah and i also feel like before this
documentary i could never understand
well the mlm to begin with but also like
why someone they get such a bad rap like
how do you even enter one at this point
right no it's much harder now that's
what i'm saying this that this is what
like their so their success was a
perfect storm of a million things like
being obsessed with leggings at the time
like it was so trendy and 2013 like
there were no
instagram accounts or documentaries
exposing pyramid schemes it was just
like a business right and so but now
this documentary made me understand how
people
a lot of people get into mlms yeah of
course it's you're being sold a bill of
goods that is false
but like if the product is good
yeah well
i just have to say like i used for a
while a rodent in fields eyelash serum
that was amazing someone gave it to me
and then like i could never buy it again
because i had to like join a pyramid
scheme to get it which sucks you could
buy 5 000 because it's literally the
best and by the way anytime i talk about
it like i'm going to get hit up with so
many rodent and fields consultants like
here use my code like yeah um
so i do think that they're i don't know
like i'm not in to the whole
i don't know as much i mean i don't i
actually don't know anything about mlms
but there is a limit to how much they
can grow now like we will never have a
lularoe moment ever again because we're
all so
hyped to what goes on in it but like
if something is an mlm and not a pyramid
scheme you're not making money based on
the people that you bring that you
recruit you're making money based on the
products sold and you really believe in
the product so mlms are legal right
they're unethical
why there are many documentaries on it
but the culture in mlms is very toxic
they brainwash a lot of the women like
it's very what if you establish an mlm
that had a good culture
you should work on that
you know like the lines are so confusing
i don't really understand a lot of it
yeah just people like so many people
choose to do a lot of mlms and then they
get like just the worst
reputation but like the mlm part is
legal if you're selling a product that
you like love and you just want to sell
sell selling you also are getting like
you know making money from home just on
selling product like
i don't think that the women who join
mlms like what i've heard from people
who have left mlms is that like they
don't love the product like these women
love the leggings yes they do that's why
that's why it's a unique story okay they
don't love the product i don't think
like they love you know the makeup and
the toothbrushes whatever like that
they're selling
okay that's what i think interesting um
and then really quickly i started flea
bag last night okay
it's disgusting you do that because my
friend abe whose opinion i respect like
said i would love it but it's time like
it passed no i know and like i just want
to say like i think it's like the worst
show you should start mayor of east town
no i think i was going to start killing
eve next have you watched it you're so
serious no no i know
i'm just like i've watched everything
like i'm so i'm at you know rock bottom
yeah
i what about mayor v10 i actually want
to watch it i know but that i actually
missed the boat on no no you fleabag and
killing me if you missed a vote on but
they're still on the air oh
like new seasons come out
where is the new season of maisel have
you ever watched maisel no you would
love it like a door okay oh my god i
know [ __ ]
i forgot to go sitting right next to me
oh my god he just you touched me oh my
god my
um
i know that's what everyone says that i
would love it
is she okay no oh my god like you're so
traumatic
you are so [ __ ] mean okay i'm going
through something right now i scare very
easily and my heart rate is just really
fast give me one [ __ ] second [ __ ]
the most dramatic person look at her get
the camera jackie you are actually
gaslighting me right now like let me
just have my moment like i'm actually
gonna cry okay
i was very scared i'm fine now i just
need a moment to catch my breath
okay
okay i'm fine my god are you okay [ __ ]
yeah i'm fine
don't act like you care no now i care
you like
you made me okay i was just startled he
gave me a fright
things happen
fights happen yeah they do they do are
you a person who fights easily i am like
if i look at myself in the mirror and i
didn't like realize i was standing there
like i will actually almost i have i get
scared so [ __ ] easily i guess i do
get a fright easily like especially with
zach just like smoking around
if i get into an elevator and there's a
person in it i scream
no i'm but it's enacted i'm not even
being dramatic it's such a natural
reflex because i'm just mindlessly
minding my own business and you don't
expect to see someone in an elevator
unless i'm in like a busy busy corporate
building but like here it's like a quiet
building my home is a quiet building and
i'm just like walking in and i look up
and there's a person like i'll
yelp and they think i'm crazy but it's
nine times out of ten i'll scream damn
i'm sure they do think you're crazy you
want to hear something why don't you
walk in looking up
it's just by the way i have an even
crazier one for you
this is moronic but it happens a lot
sometimes my doorbell will ring
and i'll open the door like knowing that
there's someone on the other side and
i'll be like sorry you scared me like
because sometimes i just think like if
it's a package being delivered they just
leave it right outside right so it's
like 50 50 when i open the door that
someone's actually there not just like a
delivery that was left outside yeah so i
just i i like i take it better opening
the door and i'm opening the door like
someone rang the bell they gave me full
warning and i'm still like
that's so funny no i know
damn
spooky season it is spooky season though
i don't want to end the show because
then it's officially like yom kippur you
know yeah but we do have a call we do oh
yeah in five minutes so we gotta go okay
you guys that was our show hope everyone
who is celebrating has a great yom
kippur and easy fast
and we love you
we'll be thinking of you please be
thinking of us
have a great day thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast monday
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available i'm just laughing
about like the the frankie thing yeah
we're also vel's podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i already
have guest box all the places where we
listen to podcast find nice morning
shows leave a five star review about our
beautiful stunning and
smart we are yeah hope you guys have an
amazing day and if you're still
listening to the podcast congratulations
you've made it to season two of the
society drop the ghost emoji because
we're feeling spooky on our most recent
instagram have a great day guys we'll
see you on friday bye